Vamos a agarrar un poco más de práctica en esto de sumar dos polinomios pero, ahora cuando tienen más de una variable.
Aquí tenemos "x" y "y", y lo que queremos hacer es sumar estas dos expresiones
sumar 4x cuadrada "y"  -3x cuadrada - 2y
con 8xy -3x cuadrada más 2x cuadrada "y" más 4.
Y lo primerito que a mí me viene así a la vista es que este paréntesis de acá
estos paréntesis no nos sirven de nada, por que simplemente estamos haciendo una suma, entonces déjame quitar los paréntesis y nos quedaría 4x cuadrada
4x cuadrada "y" -3x cuadrada -2y
más y ponemos el segundo término, el segundo polinomio 8xy
-3x cuadrada más 2x cuadrada "y" más 4
¿Muy bien? Y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es agrupar términos similares.
Déjame empezar con este, con el 4x cuadrada "y"
entonces una pregunta
buena es, ver si esto lo podemos sumar con otro término ¿Hay algún término similar, hay algún otro término con "x" cuadrada "y"?.
Pues sí, este otro término el 2x cuadrada "y" también es de la forma "x" cuadrada "y"
"y" por tanto estos dos términos los podemos sumar, si tenemos 4x cuadrada "y" y le sumamos 2x cuadrada "y"
entonces nos quedaría 6x cuadrada "y".
¿Muy bien? Pasemos ahora a los términos del estilo "x" cuadrada. Voy a poner los de color naranja.
Entonces aquí tenemos un -3 x cuadrado,
este término se lo podemos sumar a alguien más ¿Hay otro que tenga "x" cuadrada? Pues si aquí hay otro, -3x cuadrada.
Vamos a ver cuánto nos da si tenemos -3x cuadrada y le restamos otros 3x cuadrada
entonces, entonces nos quedan - 6
x cuadrada ¿Muy bien? Entonces eso termina con los "x" cuadrada ya no hay más "x" cuadrada vamos con este -2y.
Vamos a ver qué pasa -2y ¿Hay algún otro término
similar a éste, que nada más tenga "y"?
Pues no este es xy y este es un término constante entonces, el único término con "y" es -2y
y entonces lo ponemos aquí -2y.
¿Va? Pasemos ahora a este 8x con color amarillo,
amarillo un poco más fuerte. Entonces tenemos este 8xy que al parecer tampoco lo podemos sumar a nada por que nada más nos queda este 4,
entonces le pongo más 8xy
y finalmente déjame tomar este color verde, para indicar el término constante que voy a copiar aquí más 4.
¿Muy bien? Entonces ya agrupamos todos nuestros términos similares y simplificamos tanto como fue posible
y nos quedó esta expresión,
esta expresión de aquí.